hello freak bitches you know one of my
heroes who's building a city in the
Cayman Islands has named Devi Shetty he
did great man yeah he's a he's an Indian
guy and he did amazing stuff with you
know he'll offer Americans heart surgery
for 1/10 the price with the best doctors
and that makes him enough money where he
can offer a medical insurance to rural
Indians for 25 cents a month so he plays
this kind of jurisdictional arbitrage so
now he's moving to the Cayman Islands
and building what are called health
cities ready to catch the wiving the the
rising wave of Americans who are going
to be dissatisfied with their health
care and when a faster quicker and
cheaper and will fly there and I've been
looking at him as a guy that seems like
he understands what seasteading would be
he seems to understand the principles
and he's applying them by using real
islands and I've always fantasized if I
could talk to him and get him to like
invest in the sea stead and you know I
almost peed my pants a few months ago
where he was in the news and he said you
know the best place to have a floating
Hospital would be on a ship you know off
the coast of a major American city given
that we don't have that I'm gonna build
one in the Cayman Islands and I'm like
oh my god like there's so many people
thinking along these lines like if we
could just
we have innovations and technologies
moving forward and we have regulatory
structures and governments holding it
back and the world can't be held back
the world has to move forward
you don't wanna overthrow governments
that's violent you want to innovate and
compete with and embarrass governments
the way you know Singapore and Hong Kong
and the island man have done hit shows
like that too I worked with Hickson in
Texas I mean this is I was getting high
so 29 years ago 30 you know Wow and just
something happened to him in 7-eleven
and he went on stage and ad-libbed about
it too next night for two and I'm going
I'll never be that funny as long as I
fucking live I'll never be that for why
am I doing this we were at catch a
rising star in New York one night
so Brenner goes on and this is I mean
they love Brenner was fucking brilliant
I'm yeah
just he was a big act back then big
fucking act so ladies and dear Brenda
kills the fucking audience goes nuts
okay so does his set go what he's like
and Hicks goes on after him
Hicks opens up with you know I was
growing up and I used to watch the
comedy on TV and I'd watch Robert Klein
and David Brennan I'm thinking if these
fucking guys can do it so can i that's
his opening fucking joke then he goes
into that Nancy Reagan that anorexic
cunt assault
so people are running out like there's a
fire
I mean he's just fucking cunt MH comma
and he gets off stage I swear to god he
walked up to me goes what happened what
went wrong oh I don't know maybe the
anorexic cunt trashing the guy that they
just fucking loved and he was so fucking
dark just dark just what you know what I
mean yeah it's just like if you listen
to now you go out that's all right but
this is fucking 30 years ago yeah this
is 30 years ago this shit was fucking
dark you know Jenny would take a bit he
would take a premise like you say and
you know he could turn it into 20
fucking minutes he would bring shit out
of like how the fuck did he come up with
that out of that you're going what you
know anything but Hicks was so fucking
dark in his we were in in Texas this is
true story so he his girlfriend just
broke up with him he was going on with
her forever so we're in a cab and he
said she that cab driver I want a hooker
in ten we're in Lubbock and loving it's
a true story so old man so that made me
shivers things about it what so so the
cab driver said okay I'll take you to
one plate and you go to their house so I
was just gonna wait in a cab like so he
wants you to first house and the lady
open the door and look down goes you're
a cop slam the door
Hix who's back in the car but then but
did it make some sense a cab driver
takes him to another place she opens the
door and goes you're too young slams the
door gets in the car he goes I can't get
fuckin hookers fuck me ten minutes the
next night just brilliant fuckin on
hookers that won't fuck this fucking
brilliant I'm going unbelievable how
fucking good this guy is the the amount
of responsibility involved in
influencing a young developing mind
it can't be underestimated Jeff do you
remember when you were a kid yeah I do
like good stand out like yeah like like
the Sun in the sky you can't see any
can't see any star I can't see the other
teachers in my head for the few good
ones that I had yeah what an incredibly
they could all be like obviously be
great but I mean teach us yeah awesome
responsibility yeah I had some great one
so I had a few great ones there were
just really good people that were smart
and kind and they they profoundly
influenced teacher in seventh grade that
I had a discussion with him just me and
him one day and I never forgot it we
were talking about space and he was a
really interesting guy you know it was a
bad neighborhood where lived and I lived
in Jamaica Plain which was like this um
neighborhood in Boston just outside of
Boston it's just is a real shit
neighborhood at the time it's become a
little bit gentrified now but back then
it was just really sketchy very poor
kids and there was a kid that was in my
class I guess how 7th grade 9th is high
school is 8th grade because it was right
before high school and this kid was 17
years old in the fucking 8th grade I
mean it was crazy because they were just
it would they would be there for the
beginning of the year and then they
would drop out and this science teacher
was you know in this shit school system
but he was just genuinely kind curious
patient man and he talked to me about
space and and I'd never considered the
idea that space is never-ending and he
was explaining the concept of infinity
to me and that there truly is no
boundary and if you really in our memory
said you ever really want to make your
head hurt just stare at the sky and try
to wrap your head
the idea that it never ends and we had
this long conversation about it Nick in
between classes one day not even a long
you know 10 minutes maybe but enough
that I thought about that for years to
this day I remember that guy there's a
great Richard Feynman was this physicist
a fantastic guy and he's told about his
father that his you know he was pulling
some wagon and he had balls in the wagon
he said you notice when you pulled the
wagon the balls stay for a bit and then
they bump up and then you stop the wagon
they keep going so he's talking about
momentum and physics and all that and so
like all kids he said well why why why
and then he got to a point with his
father where he said well why and his
father said that nobody knows like why
is there gravity I mean that nobody
knows and I think those kinds of
questions where you really stimulate
your mind I think is a great idea I was
telling my daughter a couple of I made
two months ago about there's an old
Spanish proverb that says ha habits
begin as cobwebs and end up as chains
way easier to break in the beginning
then later on right way to put it it's a
great way to put it Wow and anyway she
just she just brought this up you know
we were talking about someone she knew
and and something that she didn't like
that they did and she said yeah but
they're still pretty much in the cobweb
face so they can probably still change
it Adam she's like well I even I didn't
remember she's like oh yeah the cobwebs
and changed things like she really said
sunk in her and she's like five and she
could remember those things that can
really take you through life and give
you real clarity I think that stuff is
great and I remember those people who
gave me those important lessons as as a
kid
you